here with a sneak peek We Begin tonight
with the speaker of the house let's give
a warm welcome to your new speaker Mike
[Applause]
Johnson
W well I certainly know my place in the
people's house because you got a much
better reception than I did that's not
true if they had SE before you you're a
rockar here and welcome back to the
house thank you for having us back and
having us back so quickly I I think this
is important for all the reasons I
mentioned before we get to that let's go
to the news the evening uh the censuring
of congresswoman TB the expulsion of
George Santos those two things did not
happen tonight they didn't it was
resolved on the floor and we allow the
members to vote their conscience on that
um it's it's important for us to beat
the Democrats on policy there's a lot of
issues that are before us us right now
but um you know there is a view here
that if you go down that road and you
begin to censor one another you you kind
of open a Pandora's Box um a lot of
members of Congress say a lot of really
foolish things a lot of talk show
hosting there is well that too that too
not you of course um but but listen we
uh we have very serious business very
serious matters in front of us I
wouldn't change a word of your opening
there you're exactly right on all those
agenda items and what you see right here
is a unified team we are ready to get to
work stick together I hope the the uh
cameras will pan this audience to see
the faces of all the leaders here
they're ready to work for the American
people let me ask you and we can we do
have the ability to pan the audience and
please raise your hands if you if you
want to answer is it possible on these
issues that we're talking about be it
border security or Israel or we're
talking about energy Independence or Law
and Order I mean can you all unite
together do you all agree that you'll
succeed together or fail
together all agree
now with a slim majority that is going
to be a a really difficult challenge it
is but we're building this on teamwork
and trust and that's what this group has
in common here they're ready to get to
work I tell you what we all went home
for the weekend well I didn't but some
did they got to go home for the weekend
to to be in their districts and you if
you talk to people individually they'll
tell you there's a real sense of
excitement in the base uh people are
believing again they they're hopeful
about the future and the people in this
room Are We Believe America's best days
are ahead of us we're going to get
through these Biden Years and we're
going to turn this country around and
that work begins right now we're ready
to do it Mr Speaker let me go to the FBI
director Ry yesterday and a very dire
warning about National Security and
threats to our homeland let's play that
tape the ongoing war in the Middle East
has raised the threat of an attack
against Americans in the United States
to a whole another level we assess that
the actions of Hamas and its allies will
will serve as an inspiration the likes
of which we haven't seen since Isis
launched its so-called caliphate several
years ago in just the past few weeks
multiple foreign terrorist organizations
have called for attacks against
Americans and the West here in the
United States our most immediate concern
is that violent extremists individuals
or small groups will draw inspiration
from the events in the Middle East to
carry out attacks against Americans
going about about their daily
lives now that's the FBI director Ray
and then he was asked the question if
our country is safer under President
Biden we call it in television and radio
dead air yeah he didn't answer for
nearly 10 seconds it's a long period of
time I think that was very revealing
what do you make of that answer um what
he just described there is completely
foreseeable it's related exactly to our
border I mean it's an abject failure the
Biden Administration the most glaring
example of its failures uh the failures
of the whole Administration and what's
happening at the border and so we've had
it open for almost three years now we've
had millions and millions of people come
in and also known terrorists and so it
would not be surprising to us if
terrorist cells are setting up shop
around the country we have been everyone
in this room has been jumping up and
down saying everything that we can to
we're blue in the face secure the Border
that's what the American people want
it's a top priority of ours but it has
not been for the White House well then
let me play tape and this would be Joe
Biden and kamla Harris and Karine Jean
Pierre and circleback Jens Saki and
secretary mayorcas they have been
telling us for three long years that the
border is secure and the border is
closed now we have an estimated 8
million illegal immigrants that I would
argue Joe Biden not only didn't enforce
a law but he was aiding in a betting and
allowing this all to happen and and
anyway so this is them for the last
three years they've been telling the
American people
this sounds to most folks like a crisis
well look it's way down now we've now
got in control precisely that the border
is closed nor could I have been clear
and continue to be so which is the
border is closed the United States will
continue to enforce our laws and secure
our border the Border um we are working
to make the Border more secure you're
confident this Border's secure
we
have a secure Border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
and our Administration we agree that uh
the border is
secure all right have they been lying to
us for three years they have everyone in
the country knows that that's not true
they can see it with their own two eyes
thankfully fox has had correspondents
down there on that border since all this
began and we've seen it with our own two
eyes all of us in this room have been to
the border we've seen it ourselves the
the human tragedy that has become the
border and I told mayorcas when he was
in the house Judiciary Committee many
months back I said I'm not sure what
you've done at that department other
than great harm I mean it's inexcusable
what he's done I believe he's committed
impeachable offenses but we only have so
much time and resources to go after that
all right well you're going to stay with
us for the full hour let's invite hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get get
it anywhere
else